just as close that's pretty amazing
that's about the same thing right Kevin
yes so that's fantastic but I want to
thank Republicans and Democrats for
coming together setting aside their
differences in putting America first
this legislation provides for direct
payments individuals and unprecedented
support to small businesses we're going
to keep our small businesses strong and
our big businesses strong and that's
keeping our country strong and our jobs
strong this historic bill includes the
following 300 billion dollars in direct
cash payments will be available to every
American citizen earning less than
ninety nine thousand dollars per year
$3,400 for a typical family of four so
family of four $3,400 and then three
hundred and fifty billion dollars in job
retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available for
businesses that continue paying their
workers the workers get paid
approximately two hundred and fifty
billion dollars in expanded unemployment
benefits the average worker who has lost
his or her job will receive 100% of
their salary for up to four full months
so things like this have never happened
in our country five hundred billion
dollars in support for hard-hit
industries with a ban on corporate stock
buybacks we don't let them buy back to
stock we don't let that happen and tough
limits on executive compensation over
100 billion dollars to support our
heroic doctors nurses and hospitals and
you see what's happening and I want to
thank what we hear also the incredible
job that's done by the Army Corps of
Engineers and by FEMA it's been
incredible they did four hospitals in
two days or three days in New York and
they're like incredible structures what
a job they've been doing and they're
doing them all over the country
forty five billion dollars for the
disaster relief fund supporting our
state local and tribal leaders twenty
seven billion dollars for the
development of vaccines therapies and
other public health response efforts
including 16 billion dollar
to build up the strategic national
stockpile with critical stockpiles and
I'm going to we have tremendous supplies
coming into the stockpile and you'll be
seeing that and hearing about it a
little bit because we're doing a news
conference at 5:30 on what's happening
we've had tremendous results on the
respirators we've had great results on
just about everything we're talking
about
Boeing just announced that they're going
to be making the plastic face shields
the actual shields which are hard to
come by and they're going to be making
them by the thousands a week and the
ventilators which is probably the most
difficult because it's like it's like
building a car we will be announcing
thousands of are going to be built and
we have a Munter contract and we have
fast deliveries as you know we delivered
thousands to New York and unfortunately
they were delivered to a warehouse which
was good unfortunately they didn't take
them but now they're taking them New
York is now taking them and
redistributing all around the areas that
they need so you have also three point
five billion dollars to States to expand
child care benefits for healthcare
workers first responders and others on
the frontlines of this crisis and one
billion dollars for securing supplies
under the defense Protection Act and as
you know I've enacted the Act we've used
it three or four times I pulled it back
three times because the companies came
through in the end they didn't need the
Act it's been great leverage I have
instituted it against General Electric
we thought we had a deal for 40,000
ventilators and all of a sudden the
40,000 came down to 6,000 and then they
talked about a higher price that we were
discussing so I didn't like it so we did
we did activate it with respect to
General Motors and hopefully maybe we
won't even need the full activation
we'll find out but we need the
ventilators I said hello today I called
him a wonderful guy Boris Johnson as you
know he tested positive and before he
even said hello he said we need
ventilators
I said wow that's a big statement and
hopefully he's going to be in good shape
I just spoke to Angela Merkel and she's
quarantined also she is right now for a
period of two weeks being forced to stay
in her house so this is just an
incredible situation last night I spoke
to President Xi we talked about the
experience that they had in China and
all of the things that have taken place
and we we learn a lot they've had a very
tough experience and they're doing well
and he's doing well President Xi is
doing very well but we learned a lot and
we have great communication together
we're going to be sent great data from
China things that happened that they see
that you know they've had a they've had
an early experience and we're getting
all of that information much of it has
already been sent it was sent yesterday
and sent to our scientists who to study
so we'll have more on that also we'll be
discussing that at 5:30 I just want to
thank the people behind me they've been
incredible friends they've been warriors
they there's nobody tougher or smarter
than the people standing alongside of me
and I think I want to start off by
asking Mitch and then Kevin to speak and
then we're going to go through a few of
the folks in the room if they'd like to
say something but Mitch I'd like I'd
love you to say a few words because you
this man worked 24 hours a day for a
long time this is the result it's the
biggest ever ever approved in Congress
six point two billion six point two
trillion dollars so you know we used to
get used to the billion it used to be a
million that it was billion now it's
trillion and it's going to go a long way
it's gonna make a lot of people very
happy Mitch McConnell please Thank You
Rosa
let me just say this is a proud moment
for our country for the president that
Republicans and the Democrats all pull
together and pass the biggest bill in
history in record time I also want to
thank Kevin McCarthy and our leaders on
the Republican side in the house who
helped speed this route
passage the American people needed this
rescue package they needed it quickly
and we delivered it's a proud moment for
all of us mr. president thanks one
community to be here I'd love to shake
your hand but Anthony would get angry at
me if I'd better not do it I can't it's
so natural I just want to go back and
shake his hair they've done such an
incredible job Kevin please yeah I do
want to start I want to thank all thrill
the real answer to America's we're
listening to you
you do your part and we're gonna do ours
and that's exactly what's happening
today
what leader McConnell did was amazing he
made it bipartisan bicameral everybody
was involved I wish we could assign this
earlier this week maybe there weren't be
as many people who are out of work but
this will put people back to work I also
want to thank secretary minuchin you've
done an amazing job can we thank you for
that and all the team that's here as I
said my speech the virus is here we
didn't ask for it we didn't invite it we
didn't choose it but we are going to
defeat it together because we're gonna
work together and this is the first
start of it the hospitals will get money
the money they need the small businesses
will be able to hire their employees
back that is a grant you don't have to
borrow from that place the other
businesses get a retention to keep your
employees on this has something for
everything into the task force and the
vice president all the work that you're
doing with this president this will be
the needed resources you need as well so
thank you for that and thank you for
your leadership mr. very special Mike
Pence Mike could you please say
something you've been working very hard
in charge of our task force and then I'd
like to ask Steve to say a few words
Thank You mr. president thanks for
giving me the opportunity just to
express all of our appreciation and the
gratitude of the American people for the
accomplishment that's reflected in the
legislation that you'll sign and in just
a few moments you told the American
people that we would do whatever it
takes and you called on the Congress to
step forward to make coronavirus testing
free for every American to make paid
family leave available Congress with the
leaders gathered around us
step forward in a bipartisan fashion and
delivered but today every American
family every American business can know
that help is on the way I want to thank
leader McConnell for his yeoman's work
and really forging a bipartisan bill in
the United States Senate I want to thank
leader McCarthy for his great work but
as the president said I also want to
thank the Democrat and Republican
leadership across the House and Senate
this is an American accomplishment mr.
president it's exactly what you asked
the Congress to deliver for the American
people thank you very much good Steve
minuchin you know how hard he's been
working in Steve please say a few words
mr. president thank you very much for
your leadership and for the vice
president's leadership you made it very
clear to us last week we should think
big that this was a war on the virus and
that we should have the resources to
protect American workers and American
business and I'd like to thank the
Senate it was a great honor Mitch to
work with you and everyone on a
bipartisan basis to get this done this
is going to be a great thing for the
American workers and Kevin McCarthy
thank you for all the work in the house
did to pass this quickly so at Treasury
as I've said we are committed to move
forward quickly and we're gonna get
money in people's pockets quickly Thank
You mr. president
great jobs David gene this is a great
day for American workers protecting
American workers American jobs has been
a hallmark of this presidency in this
bill today is another very important
step in that direction it includes
unprecedented support for American
workers who've lost their jobs through
no fault of their own but because of
this virus and gives them as near as we
could the same wage they would have
gotten through unemployment insurance if
they've been able to keep their jobs for
up to four months I think even more
important it includes three hundred and
fifty billion dollars in loans for small
business but structured in a way to
incentivize them to keep their workers
on payroll so that those loans can be
forgiven at the end of the period and it
comes on top of legislation the
president asked signed last week for
paid leave for workers who have to be at
home because of the virus paid leave
reimbursed in full dollar-for-dollar to
the employer
the first federal paid leave law for the
private sector ever and that also was
achieved on an unprecedented bipartisan
basis this is the third major bipartisan
piece of legislation in three weeks
three bills three weeks to address this
fire so again I want to thank the
president for his leadership his
commitment to American workers the vice
president as well and and leader
McConnell and also my colleague
secretary minuchin who did work so hard
to help you get this time well thank you
mr. president and I want to thank
everyone involved in this this is what
America is all about
a bipartisan approach with your
leadership to do something that's solely
needed by the American people dr. Burks
and I and all of our medical people here
are fighting the virus directly but the
virus has an impact on the American
people both directly by illness and
death but also indirectly because many
of the things that we have to do to
suppress the virus has a negative impact
because of what we're doing to give them
relief economically is absolutely
essential so I feel really really good
about what's happening today thank you
all very much
Thank You mr. president
dr. Fauci covered it very well as many
of you know I worked for him and he was
my mentor
40 years ago I think whenever we start
with one of these very serious diseases
and your pandemic the president's first
goal was ensuring the health of the
American people and that's why we put up
these very strong guidance it's been a
pleasure to work with the economic team
here because they understand data
in the same way economic data and health
data is very similar and how you have to
interpret it in a very granular way and
I think recognizing that the health of
the American people is first but the
economic value of the nation is also
critical and I just want to thank all of
you for what you've done for the
American people great job you're doing
do it thank you Kevin please
so just 20 days ago I don't know that
anyone could have imagined how hard
we've been hit
medically or economically the twenty
days ago I don't think anyone could have
imagined Congress pulling together so
quickly and so forcefully behind what
the president identified we needed for
this country this is a problem for all
of us and it's just an example of what
leadership can provide here in the White
House and then how we can respond as a
Congress so thank you mr. president for
your leadership I'm just saying as Kevin
saying that 20 days ago a couple of days
longer than that maybe we had a
smooth-running beautiful machine we had
the greatest economy in the history of
our country we had the highest stock
price we've ever seen it went up I think
151 times during the course of the
presidency and then we got hit by the
invisible enemy and we got hit hard but
it wasn't just us it was a hundred and
fifty-one countries I think as of the as
of this morning and you call Germany and
speak to Angela she's in quarantine and
as you know Boris was diagnosed that
he's positive and all of the things that
are happening it's hard to believe what
said I don't just in a short period of
time and because of the talent behind me
and lots of other talented government
what we've done this is a big part of it
obviously but not the biggest part
everybody's pulled together our nation's
pulled together the spirit is incredible
the people have pulled together more
than anyone and better than anybody and
they're doing really really well but
just to think how life can change where
you go 22 22 days ago everything's
perfect we're looking forward I'm saying
when are we going to hit 30,000 I want
30,000 that means more jobs and more
everything and then one day we get hit
with this thing that nobody ever heard
of before nobody ever even heard of
before and now we're fighting a
different battle but I really think in a
fairly short period of time because of
what they've done and what everyone's
done I really think we're going to be
stronger than ever and we'll be
protected from a lot of this a lot of
the things Anthony that we've done now
that we're doing now we're going to
protect us in the future if this should
happen again from testing to so many
other even-even stockpiles right yeah
the vaccines hopefully and vaccines
cures therapeutics whatever you want to
call it it's a lot of progress and I
think on that score I think we're making
a lot of progress on vaccines we're
making perhaps a lot of progress on
cures and therapeutics we'll be letting
you know anybody else have anything I
would just say I've never seen you shy
away from a challenge your leadership
and your policies and this great team
brought America this enormous economy
and guess what you get to do it again
and this bill is the the next step in
that and we can build back this economy
with your leadership and with the health
care team you've got here too we're
doing the right thing for the American
people and they know that I can tell you
that from the ground it's not easy it's
not easy we don't want a shelter in
place as Americans we want to be out
especially in the northwest yeah but we
know we have to do this for the safety
of our relatives and families in our
community in our country so thanks for
your leadership a great team you've
assembled appreciate it very much on
behalf of small businesses they're the
backbone of the American economy about
half the people that work in America
work for a small business and they're
hurting out there right now I'm from
Ohio I'm the ranking member of the House
Small Business Committee and back their
non-essential small businesses are shut
down without this legislation it's
questionable whether they would reopen
because this was the legislation they
now have a great chance of that and
those people that work for small
businesses or show door now will be paid
that's really
this wouldn't pass without your
leadership mr. president thank you thank
you very much you know Eric worked so
hard you all know Eric and he was at
Steve's side the whole way and then
where's our man is do I see a flower
yeah Larry the two of them
how about Eric and then let's say a
couple of words and well thank you very
much for some resident really appreciate
it and mr. vice president as well so you
encourage your team to be bold be brave
and go big and we certainly delivered it
today 6.2 trillion dollars is tremendous
so we've made sure that we can reassure
Americans that their paycheck is
protected and that their earnings are
protected we made sure that we can
provide significant reinforcements to
the American economy as a result of your
leadership and finally looking ahead to
address the virus we've included
significant resources in order to ensure
that those therapies and ultimately that
vaccine can come online as quickly as
possible so protecting the public health
and protecting the economic health of
America is what you've directed us to do
and together with the team we've worked
hard to deliver today thank you very
much mr. president since Steve is going
to work very hard on getting the money
out quickly and hopefully it could be
distributed very quickly especially when
they have some old computer equipment
that they have to use we give it a work
on that very hard days Larry please oh
thanks sir just uh hats off to Mitch
McConnell did an amazing job and House
leadership as well and I agree with the
bipartisanship I must give a special
thanks to my friend Stephen venusian
well I think that extraordinary job we
were up there helping him out and one
spot or another but he's indefatigable
and got it done and I'll just say this
was president a few months ago this
economy was roaring and we've hit this
literally this bug this virus and we
will deal with it and I think the
assistance bill here which does have
growth incentives will help lead us back
to a very strong economic rebound before
years over I think that I think we're
going to have a tremendous rebound at
the end of the year toward the end of
the year I think we're gonna have a
rebound like we have never seen before
even now at once to revenge you can see
it feel it it wants to rebound so badly
and you know we've had those really big
I guess the biggest ever stock market
surge two days ago and yesterday was
great three biggest days of the history
of the stock market and wants to rebound
so badly but we have to get rid of the
bug we have to get rid of the virus now
I'm gonna sign this and to great on 6.2
trillion dollars I've never signed
anything with a key on it I don't know
if I can handle this one mesh we can't
chicken out at this point I don't think
so
all right thank you all
[Applause]
and the workers thank you very much Bob
was a little less involved and this is
too busy making trade people wonder what
you definitely have to have thank you so
we're going to have a 5:30 news
conference in the same location seems to
be doing quite well and we appreciate
everything and we really appreciate the
fairness at least for most of the press
we really do thank you very much
everybody
thank you rare moment of agreement today
between you and Senator Kerry over this
issue with NASA can you expand a bit on
that well he made a little joke about a
man named congressman Massie I thought
he was totally out of line congressman
masse because of that I guess a lot of
people had to come back and they had to
go into a place which frankly we're not
supposed to be and you know with light
of what we're doing with with Debra and
Tony and all of the professionals so
people had to come back and just no
reason for it
so John Kerry made a little joke out of
it and I agree with his joke and I said
I never knew he had that kind of a
personality but we actually put it up
and he was right okay
we'll see it a couple of minutes
thanks everybody